hi I'm Eric Voss and if interests
infinity wars now in theatres worldwide
and as always Marvel Studios wouldn't
just let us walk it off and shake the
popcorn out of our shirts without some
bonus footage that rolls after the
credits now of course huge spoiler
warning if you haven't seen infinity war
trust me you don't want this video to be
how you learn how this movie ends I
don't want you ruining it for yourself
to weigh on my conscience
cool cool because the next thing out of
my mouth is gonna be a spoiler okay what
the hell guys he and Dana of infinity
war is so heartbreaking that there was
just no way that one post-credits scene
could lift our spirits and if half of
the MCU Heroes Voldemort in a way wasn't
enough this end credits scene shows us
two more beloved faces fading into dust
good lord
okay here's what goes down Nick Fury and
Maria hill are driving and fury asks if
they've had any word from Stark but Hill
picks up on a satellite multiple bogies
over Wakanda with an energy signature
ten times greater than New York
letting fury know that this invasion of
Earth is the most serious crisis they've
ever faced
fury orders hill to get in touch with
Kline to meet them that's probably
Cameron Kline the former SHIELD
technician who remained loyal to fury
during the Winter Soldier events and
then help them during age of Ultron as
well then on the road ahead of them an
SUV spins out of control the car ends up
being empty and then a helicopter behind
them crashes into a building exploding
fury orders a Code Red but then Hill
aids in a dust apparently she was also
in the unlucky half of the life-forms
across the universe along with a nearby
bystander and damn fury himself same
Jackson tries to get him one last
wonderful mother before he does but in
those final moments fury reaches for a
pager type gizmo it falls out of Fury's
dissipating hand and the camera stays on
it on the ground as it continues to try
to connect with somebody and before the
camera cuts to black we see the insignia
of Captain Marvel with Carol Danvers is
read in blue color schemes so what does
this mean one of the next movies in the
Marvel Studios pipeline is Captain
Marvel with green Larsen playing Carol
Danvers is gonna drop in 2019 in the
Marvel Comics Captain Marvel was
originally known as Marvel a Kree
warrior who takes on the alter-ego of
dr. Walter Lawson after an explosion he
passes on his creep powers to Carol
Danvers an officer in the US Air Force
she went by Miss Marvel in the comics
for several decades in recent years she
took on the mantle
captain marvel herself but for the movie
Marvel announced that they will change
this comic backstory so that Carol
Danvers won't be Miss Marvel attached to
another dude she'll be the main Captain
Marvel who inherits the Kree powers
directly the Kree were an alien race
with advanced tech known for their
militaristic pursuits their experiments
led to the creation of the Inhumans if
you watch that show Kree have also shown
up on agents of shield and the character
Ronan from guardians of the galaxy was a
Kree the Kree DNA gives Captain Marvel
the ability to fly she has superhuman
strength and durability she can also
shoot energy bursts out of her hands and
she has a sort of sixth sense that
allows her to predict when attacks are
coming Marvel head Kevin Feige has
referred to her as one of the most
powerful characters in the Marvel
Universe she's often been called Earth's
Mightiest Avenger the Captain Marvel
movie will take place in the 1990s an
origin story that shows Carol Danvers
getting her powers as Earth is stuck in
a battle between the Kree and the scroll
which is another alien race a set photo
showed a younger Maria Hill and Nick
Fury without his eyepatch suggesting the
movie will show how he got that six car
it's also supposed to feature agent Phil
Coulson and Ronan in his earlier days
Jude Law will be playing the Kree Marvel
actually an easter egg in guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 showed his home planet
Halle on Rockets tablet another set
photo showed brie Larson in a green suit
suggesting that before she gets her
signature red and blue suit she made on
a throwback to the classic green Kree
warrior armor from the comics since this
will take place in the 90s I'm guessing
this pager is some old-school tech that
fury left as a way to get in touch with
Carol Danvers have you ever needed her
kind of like that crappy flip phone that
Tony Stark and Bruce Banner used to hit
up cap + infinity war really they're
gonna need all the help they can get
guys because half of everyone is gone
vision Loki Heimdall and Gamora dead
Black Panthers spider-man Scarlet Witch
Bucky Doctor Strange Falcon star-lord
Drax Groot mantis Nick Fury Maria Hill
though they don't do it on the street
dust that leaves us iron man cap for
Bruce Banner Black Widow war machine
nebula rocket a coy a Sheree I think and
Wong I think and yet Hawkeye ant-man in
the wasp are still out there - I
actually made another video about where
Hawkeye might be and we'll see there are
definitely ways for these fallen heroes
to come back guys Marvel probably isn't
done with spider-man and Black Panther
and Doctor Strange movies this channel
will be digging a lot into the future of
the MCU and all these sequels but to
avenge these guys they're definitely
gonna need Captain Marvel's firepower by
the way one thing I really loved about
this end credits scene that you might
have overlooked because you were so
upset no judgement there
from the moment Fury and he'll get out
of the car it's all shot in one take
that includes the complicated visual
effects of a helicopter crash and each
of them fading away very cool shooting
it this way gives us moment the raw
panic that civilians on the ground level
around the world feel as they see
themselves and people around them
disappear this moment reminded me a lot
of the cold-open of the HBO series the
leftovers which is a similar rapture
style event with suddenly empty cars and
freak wrecks
by the way that series is amazing it
starts Carrie [ __ ] who plays Proxima
midnight in the infinity war but a
question for you guys which avenger do
you think will be the most important in
the final battle against Thanos in
Avengers 4 comment down below with your
thoughts and you know do everyone a
favor and Mark any spoilers with like
spoiler warnings you can also tweet me
directly at Yale essaouira follow new
rockstars on Twitter for updates on our
videos like and share this video
subscribe to the rockstars for all of
our coverage on Avengers infinity war
this is just one of many deep dives we
have planned for infinity war and it's
mind-blowing ending and what comes next
we're here for you guys we're gonna get
through this together the meantime be
sure to watch our reviews or breakdown
to the seats that were released early
and a full breakdown of all the stuff
that you missed in the movie which will
come out next week thanks for watching
guys oh my god
what's happening can you put this in him
post
oh is that too complicated we don't have
Marvel money what
[Music]